يبدو أن هذا الرجل قد تم لصقه
على وعاء زرع، حيث ركله أولاً ثم
حاول إدخاله في النافذة الزجاجية
لمطعم في أونتاريو يسمى
العداد، لكن المزارع
هاجمه عندما شاهد الزوج والزوجة
أصحاب المطعم
فيديو المراقبة، ماذا قلت؟  يا له من
أحمق وضع هناك مغطى بالتراب
بينما كان صديقه يتصدع، ضحكت،
اعتقدت أنه كان مضحكًا، أتذكر عندما
كنت صغيرًا وكنت في حالة سكر، أعني أنني
لم أحاول أبدًا التخلص من صندوق النباتات
من العمل ولكننا جميعًا كنا هناك بشكل
رسمي  لم يتم تقديم شكوى مطلقًا عندما
نهض الرجل أخيرًا واضطر إلى التمسك
بعمود، كان من الممكن أن يكون الأمر
أسوأ على الأقل لم يتم تغطيته
بالسماد كما هو الحال في فيلم "العودة إلى المستقبل"،
ينضم المخرب الغبي إلى صفوف
الأشرار المتخبطين الآخرين  تطلق شرطة بونت تكساس
على هؤلاء اللصوص المسلحين اسم "الأحذية الثلاثة"
بسبب الطريقة التي انزلقوا بها
وانزلقوا إلى مطعم بوباي ومن
يستطيع أن ينسى اللص المتلعثم الذي كان
يرمي الطوب لاقتحام عمل تجاري
في الصين، حيث قام رجل بتدمير الآخر بقطعة من
الطوب مما أدى إلى إصابته بالبرد.  حظي The
Planter Fiasco بنهاية سعيدة، حيث
عاد أحد الرجال وأعاد إحياء
مالك مطعم Planter،
ووجد برادن لور، المالك المشارك لمطعم Planter، أنه من المشجع أن لديه أخلاقًا أفضل
عنه.
نيويورك